alright i'm here at the chest pelvis
plastic center in st. louis and i'm
joined today with Matt Larsen who just
completed his first round game of the
2016 st. Louis autumn invitational and
he's going to take us through a key
moment in his game so thanks Matt for
being with us and let's go ahead and
look at the board whoa I get this nice
attack out of the opening oh and two
bishops and a big Center and his King
isn't really safe anywhere in this
position he chose to Castle yeah might
have been a mistake because now I she's
really getting made it um I played h5
and I'm threatening to just open the H
file sacking an exchange if necessary
maybe dude played ok for protecting h4
again and maybe trying to come and cause
some trouble down on the FI over here
but then I found this nice pawn
sacrifice h4 with the idea that if he
takes it with the night for example then
I just play Bishop d7 and I'm gonna play
series already losing the exchange but
even if he wasn't I'm going to push me
five and then it's going to be really
hard for him
so if you played g4 with the idea to
keep the each file close but even so I'm
gonna manage to get his king of the
trouble late Bishop d7 attacking is rook
and the idea is that if is ripping those
it doesn't have any square the fourth
tank maybe I could take this pawn three
go with him so if you play g5 I took 27
and here he decided to go or take this
but but not eh files fully open than
that it is really in a lot of danger I
played night of three I think clean up
six and my plan is just to do this and
this I'm a time you played rook d1 and
with the idea maybe to play this sort of
defense but after efore his net has to
move and here's king is not long for
this world he played f4 to try and run
away maybe but I didn't let that happen
here he played Bishop f1 I played Queen
g3 the simple Thunder brook h2p niche
for and then there's made us on a wed
work so he he found this good defense
Queen d2 but it's not enough because
after Bishop g4 so the idea of Queen d2
is that if F type of pitch to he could
play Queenie one and he's trading
everything off but after Bishop g4 Brook
somewhere and then Bishop e7
this idea of teenage to this patient or
checkers mas to my own so he was like
awesome thank you Matt be shown us that
awesome attacking game it's always good
to start a tournament with a big win
what do you think your chances are of
actually getting a dorm in this
tournament huh you know I don't want to
jinx it but I'm really optimistic really
hold on all right well yeah we wish you
the best of luck and let you go home get
some rest prepare for tomorrow and we'll
see you guys for another recap just
another day here
you